give us a civil liberties view
of 2020 what has happened in
this time nothing good
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant and returning guest today
is the editor of spike magazine
brendan o'neil welcome back to
trigonometry hi guys it's good to have
you back man good to be here
listen it's been a it's been an
interesting year just before we started
we were talking about how
you know i started the whole lockdown
thing strongly disagreeing with the
position you guys took and then
eventually
have come around to lock down skepticism
if you like
um and we will maybe talk about the
vaccine and all of that stuff later but
give us we're almost at the end of the
year give us
a civil liberties view of 2020 what has
happened
in this time nothing good i think uh
this year 2020 has been a complete
disaster for
civil liberties uh but i think it's even
worse than that i think the civil
liberties thing
i've been thinking about this i think
it's a bit of a red herring
in the broader discussion about freedom
i mean civil liberties are incredibly
important the right to protest the right
to petition your leaders legal rights
the right to silence the right to trial
by jury
all those kinds of uh legal rights are
incredibly important
and they accentuate the the the
liberty of the individual but i think
there's something a bit less
tangible that's really been destroyed in
2020 which is
the culture of freedom i mean civil
liberties are relatively
easily reinstated i mean
parliamentarians could
just put them back on the statute books
and there you are you have the right to
protest again it's just
been returned to us but i think the the
broader culture of freedom which is the
confidence of individuals to
make decisions to engage in public life
to take responsibility for their lives i
think that's what's taken a real beating
this year
because when your life is micromanaged
to such an extraordinary
degree that politicians are telling you
who you can hug
what you should eat in a pub how many
people you can have christmas dinner
with i mean this kind of
intimate micromanagement of people's
lives i think that has a really
corrosive effect on
people's sense that they are capable of
organizing their own lives and their
sense that they ought to enjoy
freedom so i think there's been a double
whammy assault on freedom this year
firstly there has been the
legal rescinding of various civil
liberties and that's been really bad
but there all has also been this
extraordinary assault on
the culture of freedom and on the idea
that people and communities know
better than official them how to
organize their lives well what would you
say to someone who makes and it's a
reasonable argument to make i suppose
that
you know the people who've accepted this
and who who
who are now having dinner with the right
number of people at christmas and you
know not
eating the wrong thing at a pub and
whatever else it might be
they are doing this for the benefit of
society to save lives to protect the nhs
whatever the slogans are
but essentially they're showing social
responsibility by
uh participating in this process yeah i
don't buy that
i really don't i think it's in many ways
it's the opposite of social solidarity
this demand for conformism
this insistence that we almost we all
must sacrifice our fundamental liberties
in the name of some greater good i think
that's actually the opposite of
social solidarity and and community
solidarity which is exactly what you
need
in a pandemic you do need people to pull
together you do need people to say
i'm going to look after my neighbors i'm
going to deliver medicines to the old
lady who lives upstairs
you do need people in a time of crisis
and i fully accept
covert 19 was a genuine health crisis
i'm not
a covid denier i'm not one of those
people who thinks it's a pandemic
i think it's a very serious virus
probably the most serious
contagious illness since the spanish flu
and in a moment like that you do need
people to come together and work
together
but i think everything the government
has done and everything the
woke elites have done has grated against
the possibility of people coming
together and what's it what it has
actually unleashed
is a is a an extraordinary lack of
self-confidence on the part of
individuals and communities because
they've constantly been told
this is how you must do things and
nothing else is acceptable
and it's given rise to this kind of
spying curtain twitching culture
where we've been openly encouraged to
squeal on our neighbors and we saw
some extraordinary episodes of people um
phoning the cops if someone went for two
jogs or
people taking photographs of other
people in parks and putting them on
twitter and
publicly shaming them as co-vidians so
the culture we needed which was a
culture of people pulling together
was completely undermined by the um
authoritarianism and the suspicion that
was spread by government officials so
i think they've got it completely wrong
i think this was a serious health crisis
and in times of crisis you do need
individuals and communities to take
responsibility
but what the government said was
essentially we don't trust you
to take responsibility and therefore
we're going to write all these laws
telling you exactly what you can and
cannot do it was the worst thing to do
in relation to a health crisis
but don't you think also part of the
problem is is that isn't that almost
impossible to do in the age of social
media
where somebody can see somebody doing
something wrong take a video of it bam
it's up on twitter viewed by potentially
millions of people in a matter of
seconds
that could well be true uh you know
social media does great against
social solidarity that's the great irony
of social media it's a very
divisive phenomenon in my view i'm sure
it has lots of plus sides as well the
sharing of information
connecting with people sharing news and
so on but i think one of the downsides
is that it has given rise to echo
chambers and people
sticking with their own tribe
distrusting others
demonizing others attacking others witch
hunts all that kind of stuff
so um social media certainly didn't help
but i think initially at the very in the
in the first lockdown back in march
april there was a strong sense of
community solidarity you remember
hundreds of thousands of people signed
up to assist the nhs
um i had covert 19 and then i
got all this information about how
important it is to donate
plasma and blood if you've had covid19
so i was doing that and there were
huge numbers of people who were doing
that too i know lots of people who are
working
in my local neighborhood delivering
medicines delivering food
so for the first few weeks it was
actually quite positive and people
thought right this is
we've been told by the government this
is going to be a three-week lockdown
uh it's obviously a serious crisis
people need our help and there was
there was a sense of pulling together
but it fizzled out and i think it
fizzled out
firstly because the lockdown dragged on
far longer than we had been told it
would
and secondly because the uh
short-lived moment of social solidarity
caved in and gave way
to this finger-pointing ugly climate
which is
very familiar in the in the contemporary
period where people were denouncing
covidius and you had the likes of
piers morgan who i admire on some levels
but not in relation to the kovid 19
crisis
you know denouncing people on television
for going to the park or sitting on
benches and
the police overplayed their hand i was
in hyde park and i saw police
chasing people out of hyde park for the
crime of sitting under a tree
on their own with their laptop and you
just thought well that
person is not doing anyone any harm
what's going on here
so i think um mission creep by the
authorities their
their over-reliance on um
authoritarian measures censorship
measures we saw big tech clamping down
on
anyone who criticized the lockdown for
example all those kinds of things i
think just
chipped away at people's initial
instinct
people's initial instinct was good i
have to help my neighbor
but that was undermined by
authoritarianism and i think that was a
very good lesson on how
authoritarianism and the instinct for
chipping away at people's freedom
actually undermines people's ability to
take responsibility for their own lives
and for their communities
and you mentioned pierce morgan and and
uh the erosion of social solidarity over
time i think
he was a kind of human example of a
bigger thing that happened which is
he was very critical of anyone who was
skeptical about lockdowns as i was at
the time frankly
but the moment his son went on a blm
protest
he he was very proud of that and i think
if you extrapolate that from that to a
broader issue
the moment that suddenly it was okay for
people
after the whole country had followed all
the rules uh
for a period of time with a lot of
social solidarity as you say
suddenly it was okay for people to go
out and protest and
that that i think that disparity changed
a lot of people's minds
about the enforcement of these rules
yeah i thought i think the the blm
moment was really really interesting
because
uh for for a huge number of reasons one
of them was i think
it it became a convenient release
people couldn't find a way out of
lockdown so part of me was sympathetic
to
even though i'm very critical of black
lives matter the movement
i'm very critical of the woke ideology
that surrounds it and i'm very critical
of the
extraordinary double standards in
relation to public protest so if you go
on a blm protest the police will
literally
bow down to you and treat you with kid
gloves
but if you go on an anti-lockdown
protest they'll beat you off the streets
and you will be demonized in the media
so i'm critical of all of that but part
of me was a tiny bit sympathetic
to the black lives matter uprising from
the point of view that
we needed a way out of lockdown the
government couldn't provide it the left
couldn't provide it because they were
pretty much prologue down
labour party was just lining up behind
the government on every single measure
and the gov the country was just heading
into this uh
constant spiral of keeping everyone
locked in their houses and the economy
was going down the toilet and everything
else
so i think the black lives matter
explosion in the summer was really
people saying
listen we need to get out of this and
that was one way people
got out of it the problem of course is
that
when other people try to get out of it
by protesting against lockdown or
reopening their businesses or saying i
want to go to the pub they were
demonized as co-video so that double
standard was still in play
but i think um the the the black lives
matter moment i think was fascinating
because
it really it really cut
down to size this view i had i
thought that covert 19 would help to
keep in check all the woke nonsense that
we've had to deal with over the past
five to ten years
i thought all those petty ridiculous
censorious
issues all those identitarian questions
all that
minute policing of what people say and
how people behave
i naively thought that a serious pretty
historic health crisis
would force us to confront the real
problems facing humanity and to forget
about all that woke
crap that had been taking up so much of
our time over the previous
decade or so and i was completely wrong
because what actually happened in 2020
after a few months of all us us all kind
of struggling
with covid19 is that that wokeness and
that
identitarianism and that really divisive
new ideology
exploded back into public life in an
extraordinary way
with the black lives matter protests and
then came to
dominate public discussion in in a
larger way than it had in previous years
so i think that's one question it's
really worth
us tackling how is it that even when
western society all societies in fact
were faced with
a grave challenge challenge to health to
our health systems to the economy
you know a real historic confrontation
that we faced
how is it that even in that situation we
still
fell back on identity politics woke
politics the transgender issue all those
things which blew up again in 2020
i find that fascinating but do you not
think as well that it was a true madness
of crowds moment
in that if you look at what happened
directly before
the blm we were about to kill dominic
cummings
you know and people would genuinely it
felt like that
i remember reading people's facebook
pages and going
has everybody collectively lost their
mind and
is somebody going to kill dominic
cummings because it felt like that it
went
mental cummings derangement syndrome was
a very
very serious problem in this country
and you're right to raise it because i
think people forget these things because
often people usually members of the
cultural and political elite not normal
people but people get swept up in these
moments of hysteria
and often almost violent hysteria and
then they kind of feel embarrassed about
it a few weeks later and hope
everyone will forget it but we shouldn't
forget things like that we shouldn't
forget
that there were swarms of journalists
outside cummings
flat uh essentially screaming for his
head we shouldn't forget that
um what's that google led by donkeys
was projecting all these images of sick
people
outside his home and in the middle of
this you know normal residential street
um and there was that real hysteria
there was an extraordinary meltdown
and the media the media published things
about cummings that were patently
untrue so the mirror and the observer
for example
both said that cummings went to durham
twice
but he didn't go to durham twice he went
once they offered no proof for the
second trip
they it fizzled out everyone forgot
about it the neither of those newspapers
has issued an apology
or a retraction it's just faded into
history
so um that i think is a very good
example of how hysteria can blow up in a
pretty
dangerous destabilizing way and that is
very much linked to the broader covert
hysteria
this uh the thing that we're talking
about which is that the
um the initial social connection
social concern social solidarity very
quickly gave way to the kind of thing
that is unfortunately
far too common in 21st century western
society
which is this kind of vindictiveness
this desire to destroy people
to shame people to harass them in public
and i thought the cummings derangement
syndrome episode was a very good example
of that this
dragging it was like a medieval
spectacle dragging this man
and his wife uh mary wakefield who
just for the record i know um and
dragging them into the
public sphere shaming them um
demonizing them holding them up as um
sinners who we must all metaphorically
pelt with rotten tomatoes
there was something really ugly and
medieval about that's a great word when
you say sinners because i feel like this
is what it's all about really
isn't it because there there was a
religious
fervor about the whole thing and i
couldn't i was watching it
and based on what i know of the
situation he probably broke some rules
right so he he was wrong to do it and as
one of the people who put the rules in
place you can see why people would be
frustrated about that and angry about
that you can understand that
but the vitriol of it and the sort of
there was a religious thing and and you
talk about these moments that we're
living through i feel like
there are more and more of them because
we've almost
entered this religious cultural battle
where
it's two sides both with with that
cultish
attitude almost and if you're the enemy
then you must be destroyed
yes absolutely i think there's a we live
in a very
very unforgiving climate um
very tribalistic um there's a a
a very pseudo-religious feel to a lot of
this stuff
the pointing of fingers the denouncing
of people it's very salem-like
um and we've seen that numerous times
over the past few years i think
the metoo moment was a bit like that
pointing a finger at a movie producer or
an actor and then
boom his career is gone and everyone
gets off on denouncing him as a pervert
or an evil
person we've seen it with someone like
jk rowling whose
great sin of course is to question some
aspects of transgenderism
while also by the way defending the
right of trans people to exist and to
live freely
but because she questions aspects of
transgenderism she must be destroyed
she's subjected to death threats violent
misogyny
people are sending her photographs of
their penises i mean really
vile misogynistic stuff she's on tinder
as well
but simply because she expressed an
opinion that's not
um popular and um yeah and we've seen it
in relation to black lives matter as
well anyone who says
um of course black lives matter
everyone knows that black lives matter
as much as any other
life but black lives matter the movement
is problematic and has some dodgy
eccentric views
anyone who says that is shut down and
demonized and called racist
so i said we've seen a lot of that over
the past few years where there is this
kind of
incredibly intolerant attitude towards
anyone who
dares to speak out or dares to question
contemporary orthodoxies and i've seen
some of that myself when i've spoken
on campuses for example at oxford and
other places where
people will protest the last time i
spoke at oxford
there was a protest there was a
gathering of about 50 people
they'd all made placards i mean they
must have literally gathered in a room
to make placards and i remember thinking
your students are oxford you've surely
got better things to do than mate
placards calling me
evil and a hate speech whatever they
were saying
um but people really devote themselves
to this idea that
anyone who disagrees with them or anyone
who offends them
not only are you wrong but you are evil
and therefore you must be destroyed
i want to go back to a society in which
you just thought those people were wrong
that was great you know when you thought
that person saying something i disagree
with they're wrong i'm going to argue
with them we're going to have a debate
instead what happens now is you hear
someone saying something you disapprove
of or disagree with
and you assume that they are the devil
incarnate that they are a danger to you
they will pollute your soul they will
erase you
erasure is the kind of contemporary woke
word
and so their words come to be seen as um
violent instruments in and of themselves
and therefore this person this dangerous
person with his violent opinions must be
destroyed so
that um medieval intolerance i think is
incredibly strong today and
sadly i think it's probably getting
worse constantin
how do you like your things printed big
like my ego and that's why you should
use
print it big 3d what they actually do
is help you print tabletop gaming pieces
short run manufacturing parts and even
statues from your favorite movies and tv
shows so you can get
ned stark without his head on they also
make
cosplay costumes car parts and weapons
but not real ones obviously and the
wonderful people that they are they also
make
free prosthetics for kids what virtue
signalers
on top of that they also do individual
pieces prototypes
and short run manufactured parts do you
know what any of that means
not a clone printer big 3d are offering
our fans a massive discount you get 20
off with our code
which is of course triggerpod all you
need to do is go to the website
www.printitbig3d.com
that's www.printitbig3d.com
i'm gonna get francis a new weapon i
like weapons
do you not think the problem as well is
that there are narratives
whether it's a black lives matter
narrative or the lock down narrative
and you have to swallow all of the ideas
all of the narrative and if you don't if
you go well i agree with this and i
agree with that
that's not enough you have to adhere to
every single letter
of their particular idea or law yeah
there's a huge
expectation of conformism these days and
um you have to conform to every single
thing that these groups and individuals
say and if you don't then you're
you're in trouble and that's why i
thought the the incident of the millwall
fans booing
as their players took the knee in the
millwall v derby game
i thought that was so interesting
because
to me the most interesting thing about
that was the response to it
so the booing itself was a relatively
minor incident it wasn't
all millwall fans it was a relatively
small number of them
it's the kind of thing that happens at
football they boo they chant they say
offensive things that's what happens at
football
but the response to it was staggering
you had this
instant response from the sports
authorities from
the middle class media from the twitter
arty
all these wings of establishment
thinking just
instantly said this is utterly
unacceptable these people
are evil we should find out who they are
so that they can be banned from football
you know all this stuff was coming out
and that really spoke to
how intense the conformist moment
is anyone who deviates in any way
whatsoever from what is considered to be
the correct way of thinking is in
trouble
um and and that's the culture we live in
and and you're right it's
you have to buy into the entire
narrative or you will get screwed over
by the
new authoritarians and transgenderism
is a good example of this there are for
example there are lots of feminists out
there who say
of course trans people have the right to
exist they have the right to refer to
themselves how they choose they have to
write to wear what they want
they have the right to have a nice life
like everyone else
but i don't think a biological male
should be allowed into a woman's
changing room
because there might be a 14 year old
girl and she doesn't need to see
a penis right so they will say something
like that
so they're questioning one aspect of it
which is the
the idea that um you instantly become
a woman by declaring it and then you
instantly should enjoy
access to all women's areas they're
questioning that one aspect of
transgenderism
and people come down on them like a ton
of bricks
that is seen as completely unacceptable
and the only option
for people who raise those kinds of
questions is to be shamed
and harassed and destroyed well we've
seen it with deborah so who's a former
guest of the show who's written a book
that covers this issue people attacking
her trying to get her book canceled and
abigail schreier of course as well who
will hopefully be coming on the show
soon
again uh book being taken down the
publisher being put under
all of this stuff and and but but let's
come back to
to the blm thing because i think that
that was very interesting particularly
with this booing incident because
it's interesting to me that like there
is no logic being applied to it because
we have had
campaigns to kick races matter for
people for for a long time
uh which were universally supported kick
it out etcetera
those campaigns did not see any push
back they weren't booed
and yet people are boo maybe in eastern
europe yeah
that's how we do it but uh but but in in
the uk i mean
if you look at when a british team
travels abroad that tends to be where
the racism from the fans happens now i'm
not saying
there is no racism in british football
of course there is but the
the work to kick that out had universal
support is my point right
and yet when people choose to boo the
knee the kneeling which is a very
specific thing
that is important to talk about no one
says that
it's automatically racism automatically
and i see people
now trying to present the kneeling is
uh done for racial equality well
i mean we've talked about blm quite a
long time a lot of people now understand
that there's an agenda behind that
organization that goes way beyond that
and yet those very same people are now
on twitter saying it's racism
i and i just i don't understand
how there is such a degree of conformity
and you're now seeing i think there was
booing at other games which was
uh muted yeah so they're literally
pretending that it didn't happen yeah
and it's i think um that raises a really
important question because
i think the great tragedy of um the
taking the knee stuff
in british football over the past few
months i mean if you watch
football obviously you couldn't go to a
game for
i don't know five or six months you had
to watch it on tv and if you watched a
football game on tv
um it was extraordinary there were they
constantly flashed up
anti-racist messages on tv screens um
everyone was taking the knee there was
all these lectures from
sports broadcasters about the problem of
racism
and i think a lot of football fans just
thought
hold on why are we being lectured more
than anyone else this
wasn't a key feature of rugby games it
wasn't a key feature of other
sports it was really central to football
because that's the mass
sport that's the sports that is enjoyed
by the most people and
you know mostly by working class people
let's not
be around the bush and if i think people
felt like they were being lectured to
about things that they actually are very
familiar with which is that racism is a
bad thing and it's good not to be racist
and i think the the real tragedy here is
that of course there was terrible racism
in british football
in the 70s and 80s bananas being thrown
onto the pitch black players getting a
huge amount of flack
that stuff has has almost completely
fizzled out it didn't actually fizzle
out because
some woke person or some guardianist or
some politician said
it's bad to be racist it fizzled out
because the more that people
mingled in crowds of thousands and the
more they
got to know these players who happened
to be black and the more they got to
know black fans and white fans etc
the more they realized look we're all in
this together that's how it works
that's the best way to tackle the
scourge of racism is
is to trust ordinary people to discover
for themselves through the process of
solidarity
that racism is a really stupid thing and
that is what happened in football
and football i think british football is
now a really good example
it's a really great success story in
terms of challenging racism because
there's far less racism than there was
30 or 40 years ago
30 of professional players are black
kids
worship them fans cheer them all the
time i'm sure the
millwall fans who boo taking the knee
have
cheered black players scoring a goal
many many times well the
the player of the year last year is
black that's right so um
football is a very good example of um
how
color means less and less to people it
might have taken a long time to get
there but
we got there and it's fantastic and you
know when you hear
guardianistas for example slagging off
football for being this cesspit of
racism
you think hold on are 30 of columnists
at the guardian black i don't think so
so who are they to lecture football
which has which provides
extraordinary opportunities to working
class black men more than any other
profession in this country
so um so football had got to this stage
of being post largely predominantly post
racial and then along come the blm
crew and along come comes this critical
race theory
and this notion that you have to lecture
football fans every single week
about the scourge of racism and white
privilege black victimhood
and what the elites were doing was
reintroducing racial thinking into
football
after it had been successfully expelled
by
fans and players and people and
campaigners that's the great tragedy
here so i think there's something very
positive in fans booing taking the knee
because i think what they're really
saying is
we don't want this politics in our game
we came here to
watch a game of football not for a
sermon about critical race theory and so
i think the the millwall fans who knows
what their motivation was we don't we
can't see into their souls
but there's something positive in what
they did and it's more positive
in my view than the establishment idea
that we've got to infect
football with racial thinking because
that's the kind of thing we were trying
to overcome for the past 30 years
don't i think there's two things that we
can sum up about that if there's not
many racist football fans but if they
want to be cured of their racism
just watch an all-white england team
that'll do it you'll be like no no we
need diversity
hey constantine yeah are you tired of
all those typical meditation techniques
that leave your masculinity
wanting more yeah i've tried them all
mindfulness then
transcendental and i still feel like my
life is lacking
well maybe you should try marty's minute
meditations mean it meditation is that
pun
yes it is that's right with the comedic
and mystical
marty's minute meditations podcast we
can all discover how to save
our sacred masculine from our toxic
modern selves
i swear to god i prefer advertising b
days the podcast is available from
wherever you get your podcast
and you can also visit the website
www.marty'sminutemeditations.com
that's marty'sminutemeditations.com
might as well get a beta while you're
there
but number two don't you think the
problem is is that we can't legitimately
criticize blm
we can't the moment you do that you get
slammed or whatever else well you can
you're not allowed to do it
yeah yeah exactly you're not allowed to
so
by them booing it's a sign of them
showing their disrupt satisfaction which
again
needs to be eradicated doesn't it show
that we simply can't voice
our criticisms of this particular
organization whichever way
you choose to do it and yeah political
party by the way yeah
yes uh so as many people have pointed
out
you know the idea that you have to stand
there and
dutifully bow your head as a political
organization
is um essentially put onto a football
pitch
is ridiculous and many people have said
would you say the same for ukip
you know if there was if there was a
weekly
celebration of ukip before every
football match
people would say that's a bad idea i
would say that's a bad idea but
but of course when it comes to blm they
make all these kinds of allowances
um yes it's very difficult to criticize
black lives matter
and um partly it's because of the name
of the group
black lives matter you know who no one
disagrees with that
apart from a handful of bovine idiots
probably
and and white nationalists and
ethno-nationalists who are
in my view a vanishingly small group of
people but they probably disagree with
it
the vast majority of society agrees
black lives matter in fact when i hear
these kind of you know upper middle
class white liberals screaming black
lives matter i always think to myself
what have you just figured this out
the rest of us have known this for a
very very long time
um so the slogan makes it difficult to
criticize it but i think
there's a great deal to criticize um
because
um black lives matter the movement
capital b capital l
capital m is an ideological movement
which is anti-police anti-family it's
got some very eccentric views that the
majority of people do not share
including the majority of black people
in places like the us
and the uk who think family is very
important who
want good policing of their areas they
don't support defund the police
especially they live in poorer areas
where policing is very important
so those views are not shared by the
majority of the public
and the public has the right to register
their disapproval of those political
views
that's a that's a you're right in a
democratic society and
that includes football games if
politicians come along to football games
and blm is essentially
a new form of politician and makes a
statement or makes a spectacle
and tells you to think in a particular
way
you have the right to say i don't accept
this i don't want to listen to this
i don't want this to hijack my sport
so um i think the the blm
football story actually points to an
incredibly important divide that exists
between the elites and ordinary people
and for the elites it seems
perfectly natural that football players
should bow down
about a killing that took place 4 000
miles away
seven months ago whereas for huge
numbers of ordinary people that doesn't
make
sense and that chasm size
difference between the rulers of society
and the people who live in society i
think is
is the most interesting story of 2020.
that is a very interesting story and
it's not just the story of 2020 i mean
if you
that has been the motif for the last
four years
the the fact that essentially the lee
was shocked in 2016 as i was uh maybe
i'm a member of the lead never thought
about it
maybe not but i was shocked by by some
of the things that happened
that year uh but my response was to sort
of try and educate myself about why
people felt the way they felt
um and that has been continuing through
but i think a lot of it is
also a response to this sort of
completely
meaningless virtue signaling that we now
see because
three people were shot and killed by the
police in this country this year
and last year so the issue of police
murdering
unarmed black people by shooting them
just doesn't exist in this country and
yet every single football club
is is doing this and i think that
disconnect uh
seems to me like that's going to
continue to get worse because you know
when the northern clubs start playing at
home you're going to start to see a lot
more working-class people
at football matches expressing their
opinion
absolutely and i think you're right the
the elites versus the people i know
that's a slightly crude way of putting
it
but that has been the story of the past
four or five years
right from brexit onwards although
brexit was
it existed even before brexit um i'm i'm
a huge brexit supporter i
voting for brexit was one of the
highlights of my political life
so i'm very very pro-brexit i think the
eu the european union is
is a racist neo-liberal
uh anti-working-class institution you
can see that in the way it treats
migrants from africa who are basically
left to die
in the mediterranean because uh the
european union is so determined to keep
them out of europe
you can see that in the way it destroyed
the greek working class the way it um
intervened in italy and ireland and
other countries that were struggling
economically
which was essentially to punish
working-class people by enforcing
new forms of austerity so it's always
completely
bemused me why the left in this country
supports the european union
i think that's one of the great
mysteries of modern politics they didn't
always of course if you look back to
people like tony benn
barbara castle peter shaw these kind of
huge labor figures in the 70s and 80s
who were passionately euroskeptic so um
i i think what happened with brexit was
ordinary people saying look we reject
uh this new form of elite governance we
we reject technocracy we reject the
european union we want a more direct
form of democracy
we want more control over our lives and
i think that was a very positive thing
for them to have said
but it completely blew up this divide
that exists
which had always existed under the
surface but it kind of really
brought it to the fore of political life
which is this
this divide between the political elites
who come from
a particular section of society and
ordinary people who have very very
different views
so that's been the thread that's run
through
this decade and will run through the
next decade too
and on every issue you can see that you
can see that on brexit
you can see on blm you can see on woke
issues more broadly
there is this extraordinary disconnect
between the people who run society and
the people who live in society
and whether anything can be done about
that or or how those
tensions will play out i think that's
one of the big questions of our time
can anything be done about it is there
any way to heal this divide i mean
that's the question isn't it really
i don't think it can be healed um no i
think
it's good to be it's got to be had out
yeah
um and i'm very wary of um words like
consensus and compromise
because it's always compromise
in the favor of people who are quite
powerful whenever people don't maybe
always well maybe
the thing is i think as well i sort of
winced when francis said divide because
i don't think it's a divide
it's something else it's not like we
were united and now we're divided
what what has been exposed is that two
groups of people never had the same
views ever
in the first place they've always not
seen
eye to eye the question is whether one
has too much power over the other which
i think is what we're talking about
i think that's absolutely right and um i
think it's pretty clear they do have too
much power and
this year has proven that you know they
are telling us how many scotch eggs to
eat
you know this is insane they're telling
us to open our windows on christmas day
if we have people over if you have old
relatives over
open your windows so you know what
they'll catch hypothermia you know this
is
this incredible power they have to
constantly tell us how we should be
living what we should be doing
and how we should be thinking and what
we're allowed to say
i mean really incredible levels of
governance over
our consciences our daily behavior our
social lives our intimate lives
and this year has proven just how much
power they're willing to
assume now a lot of people would have
said brendan look
i may not like or agree with boris
johnson but
you know 2019 end of the year he got a
huge majority by
appealing to precisely the sort of
people that you're talking about not
being represented
and not having their voice heard he said
he's going to get brexit done i think he
sort of lifted the skirt a little bit on
cultural issues as well didn't he flat
you know so there was a lot of that and
i find it a very strange position as
someone who used to vote for the liberal
democrat
that i've remained exactly where i've
always been in politics
and somehow the whole cultural spectrum
i'm not talking about
economy but culturally politics has
moved all the way to the left
and i voted conservative for the first
time in my life last time and now i'm
watching boris johnson
driving past me back towards the greens
seemingly
so the people who had hopes that boris
johnson would be representing their
views do you think they were mistaken
um i think they will be disappointed
um i think they were right to vote in
the way they did i voted for
boris johnson in 2019 as well that was
it was for me it was the second time i'd
ever voted conservative
um i voted for teresa may as well i
really regret having done that
but i mean there's the exclusivity yeah
there's amazing
no we're going to take out the word
voting and put in support
but you know um theresa may their
manifesto in 2017
was very positive on two issues in
particular it said we will do a proper
brexit which i thought was very
important
because people had voted for it and they
said they would not
um introduce the part of the levels in
inquiry that would have forced
newspapers and magazines to sign up to
state regulation
so those are two issues that are very
important to me press freedom and
democracy
and they promised to uphold both turns
out they were not telling
the whole truth so i regretted doing
that but then in 2019 i think um the
reason millions and millions of people
including
vast numbers of working class labour
voters in red wall areas
the reason they voted for boris johnson
it seems so clear-cut to me it's because
the labour party stabbed them in the
back i mean you really it really cannot
be
overstated how badly the labour party
has treated the working classes of this
country
they treat them like scum i mean they
really do and i think that's the one of
the most important political shifts
in politics in this country over the
past few decades has been the drift of
the labour party away
from the working classes towards
becoming this kind of middle class
metropolitan machine
very woke obsessed with issues that
working-class people don't really care
about
not interested in the big economic
questions of jobs and
housing and the economy and
people's power in the workplace and
people's working conditions all those
things that labour used to talk about
they're not interested in now
in any real way they're obsessed with
ridiculous cultural identitarian issues
and labor i think over the past few
years has betrayed the working classes
to a staggering degree
they turned their backs on the vote for
brexit even though huge numbers of labor
supporters
voted for brexit and even though the
more working class you were the more
likely you were to have voted for brexit
they i think betrayed jewish people
by allowing anti-semitism to run right
in the party and failing to get a handle
on it
um and they turned their backs on all
the people who
in various ways had been the
grassroots founding members of that
party
so to me it made absolute perfect sense
that working-class voters looked at the
labour party and said
we're not voting for you because you
hate us so we're going to take a gamble
on this guy
this posh foppish eaton
graduate who has nothing in common with
us
but at least he says he will respect our
democratic vote for brexit
and i think that really spoke to how
seriously ordinary people take the issue
of democracy
you know because all they have is the
votes right they don't have
tv shows like you guys have they don't
have newspaper columns they don't have a
seat in the house of lords
they don't ask brendan to call this a tv
show
mediocre successful comedians
doing something in someone else's
bedroom yeah well they don't
they don't even have that right they
don't have yeah no she didn't dispute
that they don't know
i pity them they don't have anything
like that they but they have
something really important which is a
very good point brendan we're just
joking yeah you're absolutely they have
the
they can't call up the junior minister
for whatever and and dip in
they can't do anything like that and so
and that's i mean the past few years
have been such an extraordinary reminder
of how important the right to vote
is because it is really the the it's the
great equalizer right the the day in
which you vote is the day in which the
woman who cleans richard branson's
office has the same power as richard
branson
to determine the future of this country
and
that's what happened in june 2016 vast
numbers of people said right the future
of this country is outside of the
european union as an independent
democratic nation
and that i think gave people a real
sense of power that they were able to
say that
um so the fact that the labour party the
supposedly working class party
turned its back on that and argued for a
second referendum which by the way
let's not forget what a second
referendum would have entailed
it would have entailed voiding the
largest democratic vote in the history
of this country
it would have entailed putting into the
dustbin
17.4 million votes which would have been
unprecedented in the history of this
country or any serious democracy
the fact that the labour party was
knocking on people's doors
and saying we are going to throw your
vote in the bin
if you vote for us and get us into
government
the least surprising thing in the
political history of this country is
that the working class is revolted
against the labour party
because the labour party was threatening
to take away from them
the only thing they have which is the
right to vote
so they invested their hopes and
aspirations
for their democratic rights in boris
johnson and i think
initially he responded very well to that
and he was
expressed real gratitude and he said he
did that speech shortly after his
victory in which he said listen i know
you've lent me your vote and i really
appreciate that
and i'll do my best but as you say he's
losing his way and he's
he's floating back towards elite
consensus opinion which is not the way
that red war voters think it's not the
way that most people think so
boris he's been dragged one way by
the majority of society who are saying
we want democracy we want less of this
woke nonsense we want to get back on the
straight and narrow
but he's been dragged in another way by
his bloody fiance and
all these other influencers around him
who are saying let's be more woke let's
be more green let's be more right on
that's a really important tussle i think
in britain right now
and the problem is as well is that if
johnson goes away where he the way he's
going and the way we all think he's
going to go
labour already over there that leaves a
huge swathe of the electorate
without someone to vote for which is
incredibly dangerous isn't it
really dangerous really worrying um
a real indictment of the state of
politics in this country
um and you know one of the depressing
things is that um
whoever you vote for you end up with
wokeness yeah
right that's what's really depressing
especially if boris goes further and
further down this route
people will say well whoever i vote for
we end up with a woke agenda a green
agenda we end up with all this
stuff about a green new deal instead of
what people really want to talk about
which is the creation of new forms of
industry new jobs
new mechanisms for people to express
themselves new forms of democracy all
that kind of stuff that
from my experience anyway when i was
when i've traveled around the country
over the past few years talking to
brexit voters in particular that's the
kind of thing they want
and they will be thinking who is going
to make the argument for these things
and at the moment
there's nobody and i think it seems
increasingly it seems to me that boris
johnson
in late 2019 was a bit of a performance
it was a bit of an act it was him saying
um
i missed a brexit and i missed the
british traditions and i'm
not going to put up with all this kind
of green woke nonsense
it was a it was an act and a lot of us
fell for it and i think if
if it if it becomes clearer and clearer
that he's not going to make good on
those promises he's not
that he's not going to get brexit done
in a meaningful way that he's not going
to hold back the tide of
chattering class nonsense that he's not
actually going to stand up for british
history and
values and things that people think are
important if it turns out and becomes
clearer and clearer that he's not going
to do all that then i think
people have no choice but to punish him
at the ballot box
but then that keeps by voting for the
kids
the question is how you do that and i
think one way you might do that is by
not voting
and that would be depressing because
there's been a real sense of democratic
um engagement over the past few years
people have felt democratically
alive and if you look at for example the
polls that were taken around the time of
the eu referendum
people were asked how are you making up
your mind on how to vote in the eu
referendum and people were saying things
like
we're having discussions in the
workplace i'm talking to my friends and
family
we've had discussions in the pub and
much further down
the list was i'm listening to
politicians i'm reading the media
at the top of the list was people saying
i'm talking to my neighbors and my
family and my community
so there's a real sense of democratic
momentum
and if that is um undermined or allowed
to die
because the political establishment is
incapable and unwilling
to make it a real thing i think that'll
be a great tragedy
but again it's dangerous because you
have
these whole swamps of people so what do
we do do we need a third party
do we cross the lib dems as a partner no
no but
but they've they've been attempts right
you've got heritage
remain reformed i
yeah so you've got a lot of these
parties but are they ever going to be
anything useful are they and will they
ever challenge the duopoly that we have
in this country
see these are the big questions facing
us and it's unclear what the answers are
i mean
my view of all these new parties is is
let a thousand
flowers bloom you know the more the
merrier let's go out there let's see
what happens
um i think a few of them need to kind of
take themselves a bit more seriously and
recognize what they're up against which
is this extraordinarily powerful duopoly
and a pretty staid um rigid electoral
system
i do think we need electoral reform i
know that sounds a bit
caroline lucas but i do think we need i
think we need proportional
representation in this country um i
never thought i'd say that because it's
such a
middle-class obsession and i don't like
to go along with middle classes
obsessions but um the good thing about i
think
proportional representation is that it
would open the doorway to smaller
parties
it would it it would allow people if if
people got a greater
sense that it was possible that you
could
um intrude into the corridors of power
because how many votes you got would
reflect the power you eventually had
that would i think encourage more people
to set up parties to take themselves
more seriously and really to go out and
campaign
at the moment when you know that it's
going to be labor or the conservatives
that's it maybe a coalition every now
and then there isn't that real
drive to try something new and instead
we all find
ourselves hoping that boris will do
everything for us
or alternatively i'm sure people some
some people hope that kierstarm will do
everything they want him to do
so you end up investing your hope in
leaders you don't really believe in
whereas i think a more a fairer
electoral system
would allow people to experiment a bit
more i think that's
definitely something that's got to
happen but i think i i think there are
two things that really need to happen
firstly we've got to
um start taking democracy seriously
start taking people's voices seriously
stop
writing people off just because they
didn't go to oxford just because they
don't read the guardian
just because they live in the north and
support brexit the way in which those
people are written off
it really makes me feel nauseous that's
the first thing we've got to stop doing
we've got to really
start taking people's democratic rights
seriously
and the second thing is i think we need
electoral reform
root and branch electoral reform we need
proportional representation
we need to abolish the house of lords
which i think is a complete blight on
political life in this country we need
to properly remove ourselves from the
european union in order to be a mature
democracy once again
and we need to fix these constitutional
electoral
issues in order to liberate political
life and make it fairer and more
reflective of public opinion
so that's the challenge we face it's not
impossible
if if there was a party that promised to
hold a referendum
on abolishing the house of lords and a
referendum on proportional
representation
i would be on the streets every day
campaigning for it because i think
that's
those are such important steps towards a
more democratic future
so any party that takes hold of those
two questions in particular
i think would win a lot of support
because people recognize
there's a layer we've got to break
through before we can start having those
really free and open democratic debates
so you won't vote for black lives matter
then
[Laughter]
well brandon you mentioned uh obviously
we talked about
woke stuff a lot on the show but one of
there's been a very interesting
development
in the last couple of weeks which opened
my eyes
to the extent of the institutional
takeover of this worldview
which is eaten i mean yes i can
understand that
psoas awoke i can understand the kids at
schools
posh sort of i don't know middle-class
schools
would be the best example which one b
dale says it's a very
it's a very progressive artsy school is
it yeah how do you know that mate
because i applied to teachers
they just took one look at you no thank
you correctly
so you can understand all of that but
eaton is supposed to be this crusty old
institution that indoctrinated kids to
be conservative prime ministers
and yet here they are not only being
quite woke it turns out but actually
also being
extremely contrary to the values of
freedom of expression
which you would have thought an
institution like that would inculcate in
its pupils
so i i i i hate to say this but if eaton
is woke i think you'll [ __ ] don't we
yes i completely agree if eaton falls
we're finished brendan o'neill had never
been expected to say that right and i
think that's true and i
i say that as someone who i think every
kid in this country should have an
eaten standard of education right um
i've spoken to ethan twice so they
weren't always work they used to let
riffraff like me in to speak um i've
spoken to the students
um there twice over the past few years
i've i
mainly spoke on the issue of freedom of
speech um eaton is this
unbelievable place it's like a super
posh university but for school
children um it's as soon as you go in
you know that it's a place devoted
singularly to knowledge and education
you don't get the same vibe and because
the one thing i always say
i say no to lots of things but i always
say yes to speaking at schools because i
think everyone has a bit of a
responsibility
to assist in education in whatever way
they can
so but when i speak at other schools you
don't get the same
vibe at all you know they're too trendy
or
there's discipline issues or whatever it
might be
brendan o'neill destroys harry potter
so it's like um so there's uh
so there's something incredibly
admirable about eaton educationally
speaking
sadly it's only available to very very
rich people
and as you say it's the school that's
produced most prime ministers
it's a school that produces military
leaders it's the school that has
produced the people who for a period of
time were the backbone of this country
and if that school
becomes woke and censorious and sees
it's
the young men who go there as being so
weak and
lilly-livered that they cannot cope with
a supposedly
incorrect idea or a disagreeable idea
that's really problematic a friend of
mine said it would
it's like um the vatican suddenly
becoming atheist i mean it really is
like something's gone horribly wrong and
so i think that's very significant i
think this year there have been a lot of
significant moments like that
when you had the natural history museum
saying we're not sure about darwin
anymore
and you think darwin you know arguably
the most important scientific figure in
history
and the natural history museum's like oh
well he went on a bit of colonial cr one
of his um
uh research projects was uh facilitated
by a colonial ship and therefore he's a
questionable figure
or you had the british museum hiding the
bust of its founder because he had
links with slavery in some form or other
you've had this real
outburst of self-loathing institutional
self-loathing
in britain where the institutions many
of which were founded
during the enlightenment with the
express aim
of expanding human knowledge expanding
our understanding of the world and and
our place within it
the british museum the natural history
museum the british library i mean these
these
great institutions which are admired
across the globe because they really
are about consolidating and promoting
knowledge
when institutions like that are acting
in this shame-faced way
and saying well we're actually pretty
disgusting because the guy who founded
us 350 years ago was not very nice
and some of our exhibits were taken from
africa 200 years ago
and and just behaving in this kind of
self flagellating way
then i think that's really important to
recognize because it suggests that
wokeness is not simply a problem of
irritating blue-haired 21 year olds
censoring you from going to campus it's
a problem that actually affects the
upper echelons of society who've lost
faith in themselves and lost
faith in the project of modernity in
essence
and lost faith in the values of the
enlightenment and are now essentially
saying
we are horrible institutions you
probably shouldn't come here you won't
you won't learn much and
you might be offended um and when eaton
is doing that and all these museums and
all these libraries
and when people like boris johnson are
failing to stand up and say
stop being so embarrassed defend your
traditions defend your history promote
your
uh virtues and your values he's not
doing that he's just kind of sculpt off
into downing street um then you know
there's a real
problem in british society and that's
something that we really have to hold
the line against we have to hold the
line against this notion that britain is
a
an inescapably evil nation founded in
the sins of imperialism and colonialism
and everything we do is horrible
that's something that's really worth
challenging because actually over the
past 350 years in particular
britain has given rise to some of the
most wonderful
epoch defying ideals
of all time in terms of the struggles
for freedom the struggles for democracy
and the struggles for enlightenment and
understanding the world
and if we're not going to stand up for
that what are we going to stand up for
and it's also as well the fact that
it always amazes me the work movement in
that it's blind spots so you've got
people are eating talking about social
justice how much does it cost to go to
wheaton
you know it's people marching for 41.5
grand a year 41.5 grand a year whilst
talking about
social justice it's people on a black
lives matter march
uh but it was the third anniversary of
grenfell no one talked about that that's
a far more important social justice
issue in this country
than the murder of some poor unfortunate
4 000 miles away
the thing that really brought that point
home to me this year
uh was the events in france actually
because
you had the beheading of samuel patty
virtually no one in the uk talked about
it none of our government officials made
a statement the teaching union's
very reliable i think pretty patel
eventually did to just right
just to be accurate yes i could tell
eventually but there was no big outcry
there was no big outcry the teaching
unions
after a bit of pressure eventually made
these kind of begrudging statements
which had none of the passion of the
statements they made in relation to
george floyd
even though patty was a school teacher
and was beheaded
in broad daylight for the crime of
teaching his children about freedom of
speech
and this is in the country that's next
door to us this is in our neighboring
country
30 miles away whereas george floyd was
killed
four thousand miles away so that
disconnect i thought was really
interesting and and the thing that i
found most shocking this year i was
thinking about this the other day
um the bishops in this country
got more angry about the internal market
bill
than they did about the murder of three
christians in nice
these were three christians the week
after samuel patty was killed
three people in a church and nice who
were killed one was almost beheaded for
the crime of being christians
by this islamist radical
nothing from our bishops they were too
busy writing letters to the financial
times saying the internal market bill is
very bad and we should say
and we should stay in the european union
um and you just think
um something's gone horribly wrong here
and then you have the vicar of dibbly
the christmas special
of the vicar of dibley she of course
dawn french's vicar
is going to take the knee and talk about
george floyd and i just keep thinking
okay what about that young
mother of three who was stabbed to death
in a church in nice because she's a
christian
why the question i have is why hasn't
that
connected with us more and that's
another
issue about the double standards in this
year
and the hypocrisy of 2020 and the
the extent to which the woke agenda
dominates things
so much now that we all have to bow down
literally
to the um the ideology of american
wokeness because blm is essentially an
american import
but when these gruesome crimes happen in
a country right next door to us which
you know britain and france are the
most long-standing frenemies in history
we don't say anything we don't talk
about it no one takes the knee no one
blacks out their instagram page for
these people
no one even talked about it more than a
day after it happened
so that double standard i think really
demonstrates the depth of the problem we
face
you were talking earlier about
narratives the narrative is so clearly
written by people who have an agenda and
until we start
to push another narrative one which
takes these things seriously one which
takes freedom of speech seriously
one which thinks it's really important
to talk about a situation where people
are beheaded for
defending freedom of speech one which
says football fans must have the right
to boo
political ideologies and one which says
people should be free to express
themselves in any way they choose
until we start to really successfully
push that narrative i think we're going
to face a really
uphill struggle it's a good point and
very well made but before we ask you
uh i'll ask you i've got one question to
ask as well which is we're talking about
narratives
but we're seeing a whole new narrative
being constructed in front of us
which is the coronavirus vaccine where
people
who say i'm not so sure about this not
that covert doesn't exist not that
vaccines don't work
or that they're a legitimate tool which
they are for fighting disease
the moment they say i'm not sure about
this because it's
been developed in record time because it
uses new technology
because we don't know what the long-term
effects of this vaccine potentially are
and because the virus is not as
dangerous as polio or measles or
one of these diseases that have been
successfully eradicated through
vaccination
why is it just theoretically just
theoretically i'm saying you know
you love it you you love a bit of uh i
was going to say owen jones it's not
owen jones it's uh what's his let's not
talk about my personal life
but i'm taking sputnik of course you are
patriotic to the core
but why is it that immediately
anti-vaxxy all of these epithets get
hurled
you know you're seen as somehow someone
who is just ridiculous
anti-science etc etc etc i think that is
that is one of the important narratives
the
and there's the way in which any kind of
discussion about the vaccine has been
shut down i find
really worrying i say this to someone
who's very pro-vaccination i think
vaccinations historically
have been one of mankind's greatest
breakthroughs they've saved
millions upon millions of lives um and
it's testament to human ingenuity that
vaccines exist
um so i'm very pro-vaccine i i
i'm very happy to take the covid vaccine
i'm actually looking forward to it
especially if i get a freedom pass
which means i can go to the pub whenever
i want i don't think freedom passes are
a good idea but i would like to get one
if that's the option
um so that but at the same time
i do think the attempt to demonize and
clamp down on anyone who raises any
questions at all
is really worrying and will backfire
because i think
one of the issues with the anti-vaxxer
movement like the crankier side of the
movement
is that they are incredibly suspicious
of authority they're often
sometimes actually they're driven by
conspiracy theories
and the sense that the man is out to get
us and inject us with all these poisons
and censorship will inflame that
sensibility because it will make them
think what are they trying to hide
when youtube is censoring us and the
government is calling us
evil and everyone is saying we're going
to destroy human life as we know it
they're out to get us what are they
trying to hide so i think that kind of
sensorious approach will inflame
um the more conspiratorial side of
anti-vaxxers
the thing that i find really funny about
all of this funny as in depressing
is um you know very on brand
but who was who has been primarily
responsible for promoting
anti-vaxxer theories over the past 15 or
20 years it's been
establishment figures if you go back to
the mmr scandal
the idea that taking the mmr vaccine
causes autism that was promoted by the
lancet
magazine that was promoted by writers
for the guardian
there were um you know lovey-dovey
tv dramas about andrew wakefield who was
the doctor
who came up with this nonsense idea that
the mmr vaccine causes autism
that anti-vaccine idea that that sense
that
um the powers that be want to poison us
with all these horrible injections that
comes from
the chattering classes fundamentally
that's where it originated over the past
20
or 25 years and so when they now turn
around and say to
some bloke on the internet how dare you
say this you should be censored and
we're going to demonize you
that to me just doesn't add up my view
is that i'm a free speech fundamentalist
i think we should be able to say
anything we want and
i think my take is i'm going to defend
the vaccine especially once we have more
information and i'm going to defend to
the hilt
the right of people to say the vaccine
is wrong
the vaccine is full of poisons the
vaccine is evil
because if we are serious about freedom
of speech
we have to defend it even for people who
say things that are incorrect
even for people who say things that are
potentially dangerous or concerning or
worrying because
freedom of speech is not just about the
freedom of the person speaking
it's also about the freedom of the
people who are listening it's about the
freedom of the audience
to use their mental moral faculties and
to decide for themselves
that's the great thing about freedom of
speech it treats us as adults
we get to decide we get to weigh things
up we get to exercise moral judgment
whereas censorship turns us into
children whose eyes and ears are covered
because the authorities know better so i
think the
anti-vaxxer stuff is going to be a real
test for people's commitment to freedom
of speech and we have got to defend the
right of people to
dismiss the vaccine to demonize the
vaccine and to say it's wrong to take
the take the vaccine that's how serious
we have to be this is about three months
nice bow on the whole conversation
because if you remember when we started
you were talking about the culture of
freedom being eroded and it's
fascinating we were talking before you
you got here
uh about our interview with dr sachara
bhakti
uh which is now approaching a million
views i think now and he's skeptical of
lockdowns he
he didn't think of action was
particularly necessary he had
you know controversial views on the
issue but he's a former chair of medical
microbiology at a major german
university he's not
a random guy off the internet but in any
case the reason we were talking about it
is that
if you look at the comments under that
we get on a daily basis
they're literally interchangeable
comments from both sides
people who don't like him saying what he
said say
this should be taken down and the people
who appreciate his
point of view say i can't believe
this has not been taken down so the
expectation
now is the controversial ideas will be
censored and it's it's incredible but
look we're running out of time so
in lieu of asking our final question let
me ask you a question that maybe
you may inject a little positivity into
the
conversation finally which is i've
always thought
the intersectionality workness whatever
you call it would be destroyed
by the trans issue because
you can have all your theoretical ideas
in your head the moment you start giving
hormones to children and chopping their
breasts off
that's when ordinary people are going
gonna wake up and go hold on a second
and i've been saying there's gonna be a
wave of de-transitioners
who are gonna break this whole thing
apart and we've seen now with the
kiribel case
that i feel starting to happen do you
think that is the beginning of something
or are you less optimistic about that
no i am quite optimistic actually i
share your optimism on that i thought
the
kiera bell case was incredibly important
i think she she's in
a very brave young woman who's getting a
lot of flack
simply because she regrets her decision
when she was a teenager to trans
transition to male and then she took the
nhs to court for prescribing puberty
blockers to
very very young people um and i thought
her victory in that court case was
really important
and demonstrated that individuals when
they club together she had lots of
support
can achieve really important things um
i think you're right i i think the trans
issue is the thing that will explode a
lot of this i keep thinking
in i'm hoping if humanity comes to its
senses
in 25 years time i can imagine us
looking back on the early 21st century
and
thinking hold on we offered medical
correction to lesbians
which is essentially what's happening
with young women who are gay who are
being told maybe you're a man
maybe you should take these drugs maybe
you should mutilate your body
i think in the future we'll look back
and say we offered medical treatment to
lesbians
we told young gay uh boys young gay men
that they might actually be women and we
castrated them
and we allowed blokes people with
penises to go into domestic violence
refuges
women's prisons women's changing rooms
i i trust that humanity has got enough
sense to
realize at some point that these are
really
really bad things to do and not only are
they bad things to do for women and
children
and and for gay people but they're bad
things to do because
fundamentally they're calling into
question reason itself
because what they are doing they're
saying that um
if you believe in biology if you
understand
that there are two sexes if you adhere
to a traditional view of
manhood and womanhood if you believe
there are mothers and fathers and that
they play particular roles in children's
lives
if you believe any of these things which
have been established for
thousands of years you're a bad person
you're a transphobe and you must be
silenced
so even to stand up for reason and
science and tradition
is now seen as a bad thing that you must
be punished for so
i'm hoping the kiera bell case will open
the floodgates to a lot more common
sense
or a lot more people having the the guts
to stand up and say what they already
believe
which is that biology is important
reason is important and the meaning of
words is important and we shouldn't
allow all those things to be sacrificed
at the altar
of a pretty eccentric identity all
classic examples of bigotry
but brendan thank you so much for coming
on the show
if people want to find you online where
would be the best place to do that
spiked read spike that's where i write
and um
i'm on instagram if you want to see
brendan's abs
head over there hello and thank you as
always for watching we will see you very
soon with another brilliant episode or a
live stream
always going out at 7pm uk time take
care guys and see you soon
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when the
video comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word